Speaker 1: Last week I received an e-mail.
From a right wing viewer saying, you know,
David, you cite these high approval ratings
that Joe Biden supposedly has, but every time
I look at Joe Biden's live streams on YouTube,
it has thousands of dislikes.
How could Joe Biden really be that popular
if he has so many dislikes on YouTube?
Now, of course, this is very much like the
people who were saying in 20/20 during the
Democratic primary.
Bernie Sanders is so much more popular than
Joe Biden on Twitter and he's so much more
popular on Reddit.
How could Bernie Sanders possibly lose?
And as we quickly learned in 2020, Twitter
read tweets, Reddit upvotes and Facebook likes
and dislikes and YouTube likes and dislikes.
It's not the real world.
We do actually have, however, real world polling
data about Joe Biden's presidency so far.
And as Joe Biden is approaching 100 days in
office, his approval at this point is surpassing
George W. Bush's Bill Clinton's George H.W.
Bush's by a tiny bit, basically a tie and
by a huge margin margin Donald Trump's approval
at this point in time.
This is new data from the Pew Research Center,
which has Joe Biden right now at 59 percent
approval.
At this point in Donald Trump's presidency,
Trump was polling 39 percent.
It's a 20 point gap.
It's not even close.
And remember that Donald Trump never even
hit 50 percent approval for a single day during
his presidency.
Barack Obama was slightly better than Biden
at 61 percent within the margin of error.
George W. Bush was at 55.
Bill Clinton was at just 49.
George H.W. Bush basically within the margin
of error at 58.
And we have in the first April of Ronald Reagan's
presidency, Reagan pulled the highest at 67
percent.
How could this be?
How could Joe Biden be polling so well, despite,
again, dislikes on his YouTube live streams?
Because the Internet is not real life, most
working people are not taking time out of
their day to dislike a Joe Biden live stream
on YouTube in order to make Biden look bad.
They're working and then they're looking at
did he do covid stimulus?
What's going on with vaccination?
And in fact, when you ask the question, where
is the approval coming from, it's coming from
the same places as in February and March.
Joe Biden has 72 percent approval on managing
vaccine distribution.
Joe Biden has 55 percent approval among Republicans
on vaccine distribution.
Biden has stronger approval than Trump in
terms of is he behaving in a way that is appropriate
for a president of the United States to behave?
And the one point nine trillion dollar covid
stimulus package, which every Republican in
the House and Senate voted against, is popular
with two thirds of the country, either strongly
or somewhat approving of the covid stimulus.
That is a big deal.
You don't get to 67 percent with just Democrats.
And remember that that's not you know, not
a single one of these Republican elected officials
in the House or in the Senate voted for the
bill.
Now, in terms of the next few months, if the
vaccine rollout continues, if cases resume
a downward trend, if things go the way that
the highly vaccinated countries like Israel
and the UK are seeing things go, cases plunging,
deaths plunging, things opening.
This could actually turn around for Joe Biden
for the worse, and you might be saying, well,
hold on, if things keep improving, how could
it get worse for Joe Biden?
And this is why Republicans and right wing
media have done one thing.
I don't want to say they've done it well,
but they've done it successfully from their
point of view.
Fox News and Newsmax and other right wing
media, in coordination with Republican elected
officials, have successfully turned attention
to immigration.
And when Pew asked people what are the big
problems right now in the United States, the
number of Americans now saying immigration,
illegal immigration is a big problem has gone
from just 28 percent in June, up to forty
eight percent this month.
That's a 20 percent, 20 percentage point jump.
And that is potentially huge.
They realize this is Republicans now and right
wing media.
They realized Biden is doing well, uncovered.
Biden is doing well on vaccines.
Biden got a popular stimulus bill done with
no Republican support.
So they are taking the approach of pointing
to something else, the manufactured crisis
at the border, and it is actually working.
So this is the potential challenge ahead for
Joe Biden.
And the truth is that no matter what he does,
Republicans will say he's failing on immigration.
This is what Republicans do to Democrats.
No matter what Democrats do on guns.
Republicans say Democrats are trying to take
your guns.
And no matter what Democrats do on immigration,
Republicans say Democrats are welcoming dangerous
illegals into the country.
And this is going to be a test for Biden.
And we will see what he can do with it.
It's sort of a it's a problem of Biden's own
own making.
It's not an avoidable one.
But the better he does on the pandemic and
the more quickly his management of vaccination
helps us get out of the pandemic, the more
of an opportunity there is for people to take
their eye off that ball and to have their
attention focused on whatever else Republicans
are pointing to.
And right now, that's illegal immigration.
They have nothing else that's even remotely
policy oriented.
Of course, they're lying about what's going
on, as we've covered before, but it doesn't
matter.
It's working and we see it in the polling
data.
So this will be a challenge for Joe Biden.
The better he does on the pandemic, the more
he's going to have to deal with this.
And we know what the right wing playbook is.
We saw it with Bill Clinton.
We saw it under Barack Obama.
The playbook is the same one.
It's an effective playbook.
That's why they keep going back to it.
We will have more on this story and this polling
data for you on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page.
You can find us on Instagram at David Pakman
show.
And while you are there, find me on Instagram
at David Pakman, both rapidly approaching
100000 followers on the Instagram platform